[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don Sakia today
we have the pleasure of sitting down
with dr. Ilya Rahman hello good boy
thank you for joining us thank you for
inviting this is gonna be a lot of fun
you have a great background oh thank you
a very deep background in health
wellness science this is really
important so you actually got your
degree your PhD from the University of
Chicago Illinois at Chicago versus
Illinois Chicago and then in
neuroscience and cell biology correct it
was an Indy PhD joined probe dual
program and it was a cell biology and
neuroscience and then and then you went
straight in like 15 years now you've
been you've been with UCLA doing
clinical medicine course instructing
you've been an attending physician at
the cedars-sinai Medical Center for 15
years that's a long time to be long
tunnel that's a quite typical medical
training and professional tunnel and
we've also been fortunate enough to take
part in several clinical trials as a
principal investigator along the same
path and then six years now at iMix and
then yeah this is the sixth correct this
is 60 year that they mix by Pharma yep
and the co-founder and CEO co-founder
Anthony you have our CEO over here Ryan
Witt joining us as well yeah what's up
Ryan good to see you so so this is let's
let's maybe let's maybe touch a bit on
before we get into iMix and what you're
doing now what has been these last 15
year journey has been like because I
don't think many people get the
perspective into what it's like both
being a clinical physician but also
being a
an instructor for others so maybe tell
us about that
so for me so medicine is a bit more than
just a professional endeavor most
physicians see on on a daily basis
what needs to be done and what needs to
be done in the most sort of pressing way
yeah and we urgently internally rate
what needs to be done the most and we're
what are the areas of need we acutely
and keenly feel that we feel through our
patients patients that we get to know
for years and then we see them go
through terrible times we see them their
families go through terrible times you
can't help but relate and it it is the
most incredible motivator that I find at
least for myself and you're jumping
ahead a little bit the motivation the
entire impetus for iMix as a company was
basically my desire to help not only my
patients but some of my friends who are
afflicted with it with with cancer so
but being a physician helps me it puts
me in a position of being an informed
person where I can actually go back and
design therapies that go straight to the
core of what I feel is missing yeah in
the solutions that are you know that I'm
currently have in my possession and my
in my toolbox I think what you
illustrated at the beginning is so
important to really lay out for people
to get there's this ranked order for
helping people so when somebody comes in
and they give you some sort of symptoms
or issues that's occurring you then
analyze and make a ranked order based on
what is the number-one most possible
thing that this person has how can I
help treat it what does that process
look like and what would could be the
number two it's big it's a lot like your
your brains processing like a lot like a
machines learning about them and making
a prediction based on what you think is
going on that ability to feel what
somebody's going through and then have
this deep emotional connection to
wanting to help them is kind of like a
big fire under people's butts that work
in health and that were
as doctors and physicians I find that
historically that has been the main
engine of innovation at least in in mind
in in in healthcare so going back in
decades or almost centuries now going
back to penicillin insulin
other antibiotics first chemo therapies
first immunotherapies all of those
without exception were driven by people
who saw a promising technology and they
wanted to give it to people who
desperately needed that so and I would
venture to even advanced that most of
those products that we now consider
foundational and sort of the founding
fathers of our technology have a hard
time being commercialized because they
did not come to us as these guts and
commercial messengers these were not the
most ideally positioned products to be
commercialized at a time so I eventually
guess that was the human motivation to
help other humans that actually forced
and brought into being the revolutionary
life changing at least for me I mean
having pneumonia I was a child you know
that that measly penicillin probably
saved my life a couple of times so again
it was something that was driven by
somebody you know a person's desire dr.
Fleming's desire to see soldiers not die
from these you know wounds from my in
fact guns yeah so it's it's that kind of
motivation that overcomes you know
difficulties that every entrepreneur
scientist you know anyone who is
developing anything and we're sitting
you know in the capital Silicon Valley
people definitely understand what I'm
talking about and it takes perseverance
patience and really motivation it's
probably one of my favorite things about
the people that sit across from me in
that chair is when they speak from a
place of heart and from a place of soul
when they say that I'm doing this
because I care about other people I care
about making the world better
that has been a continuous theme in in
people trying to make especially health
better for people over time but it's
tough because then it has to be balanced
as well with being able to make money to
further do more rd more products how
more people also potentially invest into
other philanthropic endeavors outside of
the field that one is currently in
absolutely so absolutely as I've shared
with you part of my sort of academic
path included going back to business
school this is after being yeah being a
physician and a clinician for nearly a
decade because I felt compelled that the
the music that was playing in my head
was really not translatable
so if products that I knew I could make
that could make millions of people's
lives better
it had to be communicated to the
business community I had to I had to be
able to successfully navigate the path
that included things that had nothing to
do with science yeah yet they were
equally if not more important so I
needed to build the relationships
alliances in the funding community a
regulatory community and you name it
report can be considered science though
shows ability to make relations with
people in absolute or at least a
critical skill critical I would rank it
somewhere up there exactly and I would
not diminish it and I would definitely
place it on equal footing where
absolutely foundational technology is
fantastic but not being able to to make
it translatable understood what would
the value of the technology is not being
able to build alliances in order to to
deploy that to bridge the gap you know
with a valley of death or whatever you
want to call it it's it's a gap of
communication more than anything else
yeah so that what's prompted me to go
back to business school so I can then
translate and put my ideas into into
terms in lingo that was understood by
folks folks that I needed to to bring to
my side to guide me to help me and to
make it a reality
again jumping ahead that was the the
real walk success whatever you want to
call it of being able to bridge the
valley of death that my company has
fortunately been able to to do I'm
really happy that you went through that
process and we have companies like Indy
biochem that focus on turning scientists
into entrepreneurs and that whole
process is like you said pairing
together the science with the people
skills at the same time what would you
say is before we get into iMix what
would you say is probably one of your
favorite takeaways from teaching and
from being a clinician what would you
say is one your favorite takeaway from
this last decade and a half you know
many people have you know proposed a
similar concept the only way to truly
understand any subject is to be able to
do it and we're teaching or demonstrated
you know and I'm paraphrasing a lot of
much smarter people have said this
before and I find it incredibly you know
gratifying to to see the flicker of
happiness in the eyes of these young
aspiring students when they grasp the
concept something they let's say they
didn't understand before or they
considered difficult challenging not not
very applicable but when you make it
visually understood and when you show
them the relevance yeah to to saving
somebody's life to finding it to making
a diagnosis to making a difference
between life death they see how
applicable it is and when they
understand that that's some of the most
gratifying things I've ever seen in my
in my teaching career now on the
clinical side it's very much the same
thing its ability to put together
divergent pieces of information that a
lot of times fall through the cracks you
know as opposed to Silicon Valley
we're not privileged in having a
tremendously well-organized information
systems there is an enormous push for
that but it is very difficult because we
are at the interface of human
interaction and data collection and not
very not very easy thing to you know
digitized so again being a physician
some of the greatest gratification I get
at least on a couple of times a month
where I feel tangibly I've made a
difference because I know that I've
caught something I you know I treated
somebody in a way that wasn't obvious to
others before and I know I've made a
difference I can quantify that I know
probably a hospitalization I probably
prevent a traumatic event and I meet
somebody very very happy and again being
in the community you know the the family
of the patients you know their kids
grandkids so it really you get a lot of
value from that humanistic value from
that absolutely the expanding the mind
to new dimensions of thought and
understanding and then seeing the look
in another person's eyes when they
really get it and they tell you thank
you and that is not that and that
feeling of connection is so profoundly
cool and it happens a lot to parents
with their children and as the trailers
gonna say exactly it's so fundamentally
the it's not really confined to to areas
of just academic teaching it is just so
universal you just feel just universally
yeah but then specifically aligning it
also with the health and wellness of
people too is so cool because then they
go wow that's how it's gonna save a life
that's you take it out of the realm
annoying little irrelevant actress
little details they're just you know I'm
forced to memorize and you put it all
together
and then because a coherent picture that
is important and relevant one of my one
of our close friends and one of the
assistants in the production of what
we're doing his name's Ryan Khan and he
he focuses on biochemical pathways and
pharmaceuticals and so he showed me this
insane
to means amazed that works and yeah
and then and then all of a sudden you
know there is finally something that you
see that it's implicit and
understandable and then you're like aha
that's how that makes sense so okay so
now let's talk let's talk about what's
been happening these last couple of
years so these last six years you're in
you have two drugs in preclinical so we
we currently have the entire pipeline is
three actually drugs one is imminently
entering human trials the second one is
not far behind is in actual in veteran
veteran market correct and the third one
is in the wings is in is still going by
okay well congrats you have won in human
clinical up our sleeve yes so this all
all in inhibiting tumor resistant
correct all three correct okay so now
let's break this down so we have a
healthy body and then all of a sudden we
have what occurs to even form a tumor
typically in the first place all right
harping back to the confusing
biochemical chart now picture that and
toss it out of your memory okay get rid
of it okay all right yeah there is no
sequential steps here think of parallel
processes mm-hmm which is partly why the
tumors are so difficult so difficult to
to conceptualize and treat okay it's a
parallel process think of massive
parallel evolution happening in multiple
cells yes yes and then all the different
workings of the self-exam at the same
time yes exactly different portions of
the tumor are different city-states
what evolved at the same time so tumors
not composed humor is the same is not a
uniform mass it's not it's in the most
simplistic form it's a three-dimensional
mass that contains so many local
environments they differ from each other
that impose evolutionary drive and as
all politics are local so is the
the pressure and the tumors low crying -
for the SCI populations that are closer
to the blood vessel the tumor pressure
is not at the evolutionary pressure to
survive is not as high as two cell
populations that are further removed
from a blood vessel where there's a lot
less oxygen a lot less glucose that's
just a very basic basic premise that is
now well understood and we call it the
tumor microenvironment
tumor micro-environment from a
neuroscience background for the Y you
know for the last 18 - 20 years you know
I was taught to think in those terms so
when I and that is why I made the
transition from neuroscience to Tauron
college to bring it to cancer research
is that's what I saw the gap so cancel
we're still being treated as a
homogeneous Mouse without you know
without respecting the network's within
without paying attention to the
divergent evolutionary pressures on each
tumor population and even what's on the
outside of the tumor that's resisting
that and then again as a clinician what
you notice is a very typical path the
patients get their first course of
therapy almost universally too much
drink in almost universally and I'll
talk about static cancers almost
universally cancers return 3 6 9 months
later and then they're progressively
less responsive to anything that we give
them so what what exactly are we talking
about right now say we gain some sort of
uh cancer cells or tumor and then
there's a treatment there's a tree what
is that what is that treatments the
treatments usually still with the
exception of few tumors in the
metastatic setting still include radio
in chemotherapy it's beginning to change
and there's rapid innovation as we speak
where the immunotherapy and other
therapies coming online and chemotherapy
usually it's traditionally Audis correct
so the key keep both chemotherapy
radiation or chemotherapy is giving
systemically so it's given intravenously
sorry it's
circulates around the body it hopes to
kill preferentially the rapidly dividing
cells which are the two rapidly dividing
tumor cells and it does so but it does
but at the same time because it's a
toxin it induces the very resistance
mechanisms that then produce the next
generation of the resistant cancer
return and they're no longer sensitive
and they're no longer sensitive to
multiple other lines of treatments
they're no longer sensitive to chemo and
they a lot of times sensitive to
immunotherapies as well so the question
that interested me how do we break the
vicious cycle yes and as it turns out if
you do if you dig into basic science
that has been that's been around for a
little while unfortunately some
relationship doesn't come from the
console itself so you have to sort of
expand to other areas of scientific sort
of disciplines and you look at how
evolutionarily preserved those
resistance mechanisms are then you begin
to actually get curious of what if you
can tamper those but if you can inhibit
those yes and could we attack them so
that not only your standalone therapy
but other therapies correct become less
susceptible to the escape and to the
resistance emergence now how are you
breaking down the resistance of these
tumors so so what we do is we record in
ischl II the hypothesis was that the
tumors are in a very sort of overly
simplified graphical so in image and
image analogy is a fetus that is growing
inside our bodies which are placentas
that's supported it's actually not that
far from the truth in that our tumor
tumor cells are usually embryonic
versions of ourselves so they did
differentiate towards the the fetal or
the embryonic form so that they're less
immunogenic
then they can attract more blood vessels
because anything that needs to grow
beyond a certain size I'll say one cubic
centimeter you have to be able to grow
new blood vessels to support the the
growth of this 3-dimensional mass how do
you do this
so if you're a tumor you secrete
inflammation cytokine information
molecules so inflammation is the
language the tumor uses to communicate
and elicit support from us from our own
bodies from the host so that if you
extend that logic of thinking then you
think okay so it actually uses
inflammation to attract support so
instead of trying to kill it with toxins
what if I withhold what if I block those
lines of communicated what if I block
the SOS saw you know signals from tumors
and we just aboard the tumor so the idea
is that you would just stop having that
placentas the host support the parasite
growing inside of us what if we cut off
so the hypothesis so what do we need we
need to selectively deliver to the areas
of tumors inflammation blockers but not
a specific targeted because remember
even in the most simplistic schema we
have twenty or thirty thirty thousand
genes and then all those get spliced and
modified so we're talking about an
infinite number of modifications and
that's how we approach oncology now we
target it and the better target that we
are the better we consider it better
known the more characterize the targets
are which is great if you have a
singular specific static disease we
thought it would be terrible for an
evolving dynamic multi clonal process
notice which the solid tumors are so in
the liquid terms which I'm a clonal it
works really really well and we see that
there's a fantastically successful
immunological immunological approaches
right curing leukemias lymphomas we have
an me
that's sort of a spectacular success on
the solid tumor because of the
multi-core nature mm-hmm so you know our
hypothesis was to build a delivery
vehicle that would deliver these
inflammation suppressors that would
inhibit top-down entire inflammation
cascade not just anyone but the head
regulators mm-hmm and colluded with a
very small amount of a toxic substance
that would activate apoptosis cell death
because in tumors as in our fetal cells
apoptosis which is regulated controlled
cell death programmed cell death process
is actually inhibited so the switch is
off so how do we flip it back on we give
the anti-inflammatory really really
potent inflammation suppressor which
reactivates the switch and then you give
the second molecule that flips the
switch on and you then are able to dis
inhibit and activate mm-hmm okay so
that's schematically what we did let's
see let's see let's let's do a we some
of the field summary okay so we have a
tumor that's sending SOS signals
cytokines inflammation molecules I am in
Flay I need an I need attention from the
body I need attention I need resources
and then the body is like okay give give
give so the first step is to fit is for
your this is your intellectual property
correct is this first part is the first
molecule that inhibits the inflammation
correct of that area correct
specifically targeted in from that not
other parts of the body just that tumors
okay okay and then after inside the same
particle there's a second maliki exact
inside yes and yeah same same
nanoparticle is second molecule okay and
then the second molecule
small cytotoxic okay and then that is
what causes apoptosis all right
motivation and that activation of a
produce because normally we have
apoptosis occurring in the body nor act
normally but the tumor flips it off it
suppresses that suppressor yeah not only
that it gets even more devious it does
two broad things at the same time like
how you speak about it devious to the
machine to survive at any cost and what
it does yeah the same thing not only
does it secrete the SOS help me sign it
also secretes signals that activates
immunosuppression it actually acting its
production of clothes of cells that we
call T regulatory cells that actually
suppress and make our immune system
think that we have to protect this new
developing tissue and it actually blocks
our own immune system from attacking it
because our T cells are trying to target
it and kill it however why is the tumor
trying to do
it's trying to prevent our T cells it
activates and actually create activates
and activates creation of T cells bone T
cells T cells from our own bone marrow
okay that's suppress other two cells
from killing it Wow so there's a little
mini wardrobe exactly exactly and that
is one of the main barriers to immune
oncology which we also think we've sort
of found the key to overcome this is so
interesting it's an inch an interlinked
Network so it isn't just in just like in
any network if you you know display so
if you alter any part of the network you
conduct because remember we are walking
physical chemistry we operate our
energies right so if you if you provide
any energy input energy on this side
it's going to transmit some energy and
you're gonna get all these unintended
consequences the very much definition of
a network effect whoa the way that it's
described as a as becoming this separate
sort of parasitic
inside of the body is kind of disgusting
but it's it's but it's natural it's a
very natural thing that the body ages
over time senesce is and then at some
point there are gonna be these
malevolent things that occur inside of
us and then now we have to figure out
how to inhibit that suppress it turn it
around hopefully kill it right then and
there in a targeted way that doesn't
affect the other parts of the body and
maybe then we can live longer maybe that
our grandparents and our parents and
their kids can live longer and actually
this argument is very very interesting
very recently recently I I stumbled into
Eric Weinstein's and Jun eun-suh are
pretty great arguments about about this
because I love all three of them hung
out with all three of them hosting them
on the shows and everything and the
recent sort of push for longevity is
actually for creativity for education
for thriving and prospering this has
nothing to do with being some immortal
God this is everything to do with just
like I want to learn more about the
cosmos that we live in and I want to be
able to be more creative in this world
and I really over longer periods of time
and that really resonated with me
because I think about how little I know
about everything and I just want to keep
learning and making all these great
connections and more I want to hang out
with other really creative people and
and so that's this argument is that you
know not only do not want your
grandparent to die when they're 60 but
you also want them to potentially be
able to do more creative work for
another couple decades that can
potentially have more moments of
innovation what if they come up with the
next big thing when they're 68 and they
weren't able to so this is all why it's
so important so so crucial yeah so the
things that that we now tend to call it
in health is health span right we not
only focus on lifespan we want it to be
a health span so you want to extend the
functional high quality years why so
from my past life of neuroscience we
know that with age brain is a funny
machine it actually gets better in terms
creativity in terms of finding novel
solutions because we're able to make new
new collection new and new connections
based on the synaptic plasticity in you
know stimulated and produced by our
experiences by integrating visual
auditory and all kinds of cognitive
inputs yeah so I very much support that
vision and and I see that in action also
how can we retain the 13 year old
homeostatic capacity until we're 80 that
would be so amazing like you're 80 years
old and you just like don't feel your
body comes right back to equilibrium
much better so okay so now let's let's
go let's go deeper into this so in the
in the moment of my body let's say
turning 40 let's just start from from
that point quick what actually occurs in
the first formation of the tumor what's
what's like the first sign that the
tumors has started you actually reminded
me of a great point okay so if we go
back to and we actually consider tumor
initiation or origination in it's more
holistic sense I think it would probably
be useful to reframe it a little bit and
get away from the hyper zoomed in focus
on the tissue where the tumor comes from
where how most of us think about tumors
now and actually think of it in terms of
it takes two to tango so it actually
takes the the number one participation
factor tumors is aging but aging of what
not just the tissue itself but also the
bone marrow the part of the immune
system that provides the surveillance
mmm-hmm so it is not so clear in my mind
at this point at least you know is it
the just the breakdown of the target
tissue or the insufficient surveillance
by the immune system that allows this
yes you know let's say oxidize damaged
tissue that was stimulated to begin down
this path of becoming transformed and
sort of DJ friendship over towards
cancer right but why isn't it getting
cleaned up in
I wanna you know share a very cheerful
thought with you that as we speak
there's probably millions of little you
know vocal formations of cute of cancers
and tumors forming inside each of us
yeah but we are quite efficiently wiping
exactly wiping them away the healthy
functional immune system we think it's
that more narrow direct that's a lot
millions inflammation is that our God
being influenced by micro bio we just
flew in so we probably got a fair dose
of radiation to our skin so we are
bombarded constantly yet we have a
terrific defense system in the form of
the immune cell immune cell populations
that you know that skin our environment
and remove those harmful potentially and
potentially deadly parasite that could
take us over so it's not only the single
location that's a body's immune system
is precisely what is the relationship
between bone marrow and immune system so
the bone marrow is is one of the largest
Depot's of stem cells that provide this
this renewing source of immune sort of
surveilling cells along with some big
organs like liver and spleen and others
but bone marrow serves as the is the
sphere that the supply the supply source
of newly differentiating cells that
differential from stem cells to the
mature cells of the plant here say then
decreasing the bone marrow over time
function function of bone marrow
increases immune cells in the liver and
other organs that provide you know
healthy and functional white cell
monocytes lymphocytes sources of t-cells
sources of those policing cells that
scan and scavenge the damaged cells that
could become neoplastic so it you know
as well as the breakdown of tissue
organization so we know that if you
breakdown
tisha wide signals you have these rogue
individual cells that will try to become
very selfish and they will try to
differentiate and grow in the which
would be very reminiscent of tumors so
these these are models that have been
tested in tissues so they were taken and
all again and they would plant you know
that would explain the tissue and they
would see that if you stop providing
organizing signals something to keep the
tissue as a one solid block all of a
sudden you see all these clones escaping
on their own so it takes so cancer is a
failure of organization it's when it's
when members of our organization become
sort of they go rogue and they become so
selfish that they do anything to survive
at the expense of the tissue host so all
right so now we have this insane
parasite that's built up inside of us
it's sending this SOS mo of inflammation
your first cutting off that signal of
inflammation and then their second
telling this tumor die correct time to
die okay so that's your process across
all three oh three oh three okay at the
moment yes okay and so the one that's in
the one that's in in human trials I
guess I guess maybe a good question to
ask is between those three if they're
all kind of they're not this they are
the same two molecules of doing the same
platform they contain the same
anti-inflammatory one of them can one of
them contains an antibody fragment that
targets so on the surface the targets
this particle to be taken up by tumor
cells with even greater affinity we've
engineered that so we can target it to
the brain a bit more and a bit more to
cells that are harder to reach okay so
the different parts of the body is the
different three potentially potentially
but the core of the molecule is the same
got it okay between the first two
molecules
okay and and okay so now the one that's
the one that's in human what human
clinical trials now what was the success
in the mouse trials tell us about what
the results were so going back so
initially when we tested our hypothesis
for this approach so we wanted to see
would it work in tumors that just from
my personal personal experience we're
near and dear to me for and we tested it
in metastatic colon and ovarian cancers
hmm so we took cancer models cancer cell
lines that were made resistant to
doxorubicin so they were growing just
fine in the presence of chemotherapy and
there and we then took these clones
implanted them in mice
allowed them to grow to take and then we
gave our drug and our drug incidentally
contained at that time about 3% of the
currently used doxorubicin so even when
a hundred percent was resistant we were
able to completely block the growth of
those tumors at about 3% Wow
did those correct so that that's served
in our minds as sort of a validation of
principle and that was the beginning
that was the blocking the SOS so was the
blocking this and activating and
activating the apoptosis did it die too
when we increased the dose light he did
like to six or 80 percenter to twelve or
uh we so actually we started in even
lower dose so when we increase the dose
of the anti-inflammatory not the chemo
the the chemo dose didn't really matter
yeah what needed to be blocked was the
SOS yes yeah we were able to increase
the anti-inflammatory component maybe
fifty percent fifty cool and then that
cost that caused apoptosis and shrinkage
of breast cancer model which was at that
time also study actually still remain
it's quite difficult to treat and even
in mice did it fully die or shrunk so
each shrunk
it's wrong to the point of being barely
if if noticeable in the lab mm-hmm but
what was very interesting is that the
persistence of the response was
impressive that's really important you
know so we went out to approximately
they fifty which is quite a typical
cutoff point in mice in a translation
just something like you know somewhat
within three nine months in human life
mm-hmm and the response actually
persisted so that was stayed small stay
small
it didn't regrow and how often were they
administering so at that time we gave
seven injections every other day one
injection every other day seven times
okay that's it for the whole period
that's it seven total injections the
concept was that if this is indeed a
unicellular self cells de-differentiate
evolving cells they are evolving towards
a unicellular status single cells which
is a parasitic or bacterial infection
and we should treat metastatic cancer as
such as a really severe infection how do
we treat infections we don't give them a
whopping dose of anything once we give
him appropriate dose of antibiotic
intravenously for about a week so that
was that was the conceptual framework we
took that framework when we saw that
we're getting fairly uniform response
against across five divergent tumor
types
so we then since then we extend so we
extended our father studies from coal
and ovarian to then breast glioblastoma
brain tumor
multiple myeloma and some others have
one more solid but then think we
actually then we were lucky enough
fortuitously we were thrown a challenge
if we thought that our drug was so
effective that we were offered to test
our therapeutic in the in the genetic
model of pancreatic cancer KPC model
that model offers a unique advantage
over everything else that we had done a
up until that point is that that tumor
model behaves very similar to a human
patient it is minimally sensitive to
chemotherapy almost not sensitive to
chemo radiation and immunotherapies have
had a really hard time making a dent so
fab in our minds that would have been
the closest approximation to the human
model so we eagerly took up the
challenge and it was quite gratifying to
see the results at that point decided to
make it even more realistic because we
wanted to subject the tumor system to a
more prolonged exposure to our drug so
we can get at those pesky stem cells
that have a very long life cycle so if
you kill it if you hit it today you know
they may be dormant for three days I
mean I divided for a week so that's why
we wanted to go every day for five days
just like we would treat a really severe
infection in the hospital and we saw a
near uniform shrinkage but not only
shrinkage when we cut those tumors what
we saw was essentially nothing but a
scar with wholesale rearrangement of not
only the tumor but the immune micro
environment so we saw disappearance of
those suppressive t-regulatory cells
which keep our good immune system out of
the tumor we saw near complete
disappearance of new blood vessels
because we block the SOS signals and
they could no longer attract them and we
saw pretty remarkable tumor shrinkage on
top of that so that that gives us the
greatest hope that we are onto something
promising and gives us some sense of
anticipation what we're gonna see in the
clinic amazing so think you work yeah
it's so good it's so important this is a
big team right that was able to do this
very big very diverse team small
scattered all over the globe which
you know gives me an incredible
appreciation for really people's
contributions from all walks of life
disciplines countries corners of the
world how many total people are you have
oh boy alright so we while we grew
organically we ended up going very
quickly over the last year or two so it
was three founders initially who all
came from extremely diverse background
you know physician scientist biotech
patent attorney physical chemists then a
finance preferably professor in a
professional and the subsequently O'Ryan
with who is entrepreneur in the
regulatory guru we and from that point
on we're collaborating with the world's
premier nano chemical nanotechnology
formulators yeah toxicology experts
clinical trial list we are now proud and
honored to have one of the leading
oncologists in Australia lead our
upcoming phase 1 trial who is incredibly
excited and understands the approach
that we're taking so it's it's a
humbling experience truly yeah to build
you so many smarter people around you
basically yes show us the path forward
we always like highlighting the team
because the person that's the leading
you know voice of the team is usually
the one that gets a lot of the tension
highlight but it would be zero and
that's exactly what we have here at with
simulation we have our producing partner
on Vargas without him would be anything
alesis in LA our photographer there's
all these team members that that help
make it really a thing come true
so I'm amazing ok let's walk you through
because I want to still get yeah let's
let's get to some of the some of our
questions do you want to highlight
anything else from what you're doing
that you think is really important to
mention before I walk you through a
couple questions maybe why don't we take
some of the questions all right go
through it might exactly might remind me
I might be missing some crucial piece
that
we'd like to share okay cool so how
about ass as a first question as
somebody that really got deep into
understanding brain do you think that
consciousness is localized in the
nervous system absolutely not okay
absolutely not tell us more so
consciousness is it's probably deep so
consciousness is definitely a product of
our nervous system it is almost solely
not localized in any nucleus of the
brain it is clearly a distributed
function and it's a function of but
occurs all within the body though or
does support each individual person yes
okay so consciousness is then localized
in the body itself so mmm perhaps it
might be simpler or might be I might be
able to get to the point easier if I
tell you my how I view the brain okay so
the brain is in the nervous system by
extension so nervous system is is the
most refined way of processing and
integrating us in terms of our larger
environment yes making us adaptable and
surviving in our environment in
providing the most appropriate outputs
behavioral output seeing a motor output
in response to the inputs yes in the
environment that we find so that is
probably that's where I'd say there's
enough scientific basis for me to almost
unambiguously state that much where the
logic conscious you know is a societal
conscience or our personal conscience
where that lies I would probably leave
somewhere in between yes so you so
there's a there's a line that kind of
gets a little blurred out of them once I
get my inside consciousness then there's
maybe some sort of a line between your
consciousness and mind but then there's
also some sort of a connection cut out
between the consciousness is and even
the whole earth
consciousness you know and it's very
difficult to disentangle because there's
so many nonverbal cues that we are
passing as we speak passing between the
two of us that there are millions of
waves sound waves you know visual waves
etc so there's so many nuances being
exchanged as we speak and it takes a
tremendous amount of Integrative ability
to process that and then reverberate
reciprocate so that's why I think the
incredible difficulty in assessing what
the thing is I think comes from okay
that's good that's good I was good
answer
it's the most realistic answer I can
give you out about without dumbing it
down B which is enormously complicated
complex object you did it you did a
quite a great job at it do you think
that the do you think that the cosmos
birthing the nervous system the human
nervous system into existence do you
think that this is the only vehicle of
perceiving and understanding the cosmos
or do you think there are other sorts of
these nervous systems around other stars
so do you think we're alone in that
sense I think it's very difficult to
presume that we're alone now every five
or ten years as for example my cousin
finds a new nuclear so sub-nuclear
particles he's a nuclear physicist
things that I can only hope to
understand yet somehow statistically I
understand that there are levels of
entire universes yeah that I don't even
understand so it's very difficult for me
to imagine that this is the only way to
perceive universe that this is the only
universe that exists out there because
how do we perceive so our perception is
limited initially by our sensory organs
which are only evolved to deal with a
very narrow portion of the spectrum if
you take you know the light spectrum and
a very narrow spectrum right same thing
with the sounds better now I dig deeper
how many different you know sensory
mechanisms
you have a new technology now you sense
something that we don't we don't have
sensory machinery to to sense those
things now extend that I think it's
clear to me that there's so many new so
many more levels out there that yeah
we're not even pre at the moment at the
moment and soon will augment our ability
to feel and perceive and that would be
very fascinating when we own house we're
getting there what do you what do you
think about this new age of genetic
engineering that's coming into play so
even more specifically with potential
augmentations and intelligence in
metabolism yeah yeah fasting fantastic
so this is one of the subject areas that
I'm glad you bring up I forgot to talk
about this is a beautiful example so for
the last 20 years I've been holding my
breath right
ever since the the sequencing of the
human genome and ever since people kept
tossing around the junk DNA and my you
know my heart would bleed because it was
inconceivable to me that 97 percent of
our genome was junk yet I couldn't
reconcile if you go back not only not
only between two individuals do we have
a near identical coding gene but then
when you go back to other species we're
like between 98 to 60 percent identical
where some lowly little beast out there
in the forest 50% to a banana makes no
sense right how is the rest of the junk
so in my mind it was clearly the
regulatory sequences where the money was
so to speak you can so the only
difference between you and it really
taught a really short person in a very
simplistic form is the regulatory
sequence now decoding it's not what
you're made of
you're both made of identical collagen
it's just how long that person's
collagen gene is turned on so the news
we got longer or shorter yeah but
they're made of the identical material
and that's the way the gene expresses in
exactly okay not only gene now extend
that metabolism epigenetically the
molecular clock to express that's the
question then the regulatory sequences
okay which we know because is
decoded to encode the human genome
project we have that information
lying there up until a few years ago
used to be called jock DNA
so now folks have realized that that's
the regulatory knobs mm-hmm and I would
venture to guess in the next five years
you will have knobs that make you age
faster or slower we already know that
you know metabolic measures very
primitive first versions you know
[Music]
calorie restriction will slow you maybe
that would be the exact speed up your
metabolism your aging you can slow it
down by calorie restriction other
medicines that are currently in clinical
trials right mTOR and that's forming
other agents but do what knobs do we
have them do we have the knob for height
and the knob for eye color the knob for
intelligence where are we at these knobs
because these gene expressions they're
difficult to understand the genes for
intelligence that's a very difficult one
they definitely be the gene for height
or is just a couple it's a little bit
easier me so they're difficult to
understand because it's not only the
matter of genes but where they end up at
the same time so as you're building a
building physical structure you can't
say that if I make one column taller my
building is gonna be tall so you have
the coordinate exactly so when you start
thinking in terms of networks in
building holistic three-dimensional
structures you begin to understand you
know how complex yes but you need the
right framework right if you're not even
in the same vicinity if you know if your
framework is wrong it's very difficult
to give anywhere if you get the
framework right then it becomes just a
matter of machinery technology and tools
which are skyrocketing in complexity in
ability the ability to process
information so now I'm very hopeful that
the next five to ten years will probably
have as much progress as we made in the
previous 40 or 50 years yes symbiosis
and it seems to continuously be
happening in the last couple of decades
as these next couple years have as much
progress the last couple of decades and
it's really beautiful
more and more energy and talent and
resources being dedicated in that a
question about what do you think as a
lot of wealth is being concentrated in
just a couple people eight people have
as much as the bottom four billion
people what do you think even though the
Pinker arguments sure everybody slowly
coming up but all that I all the
technologies exacerbating the wealth and
equality what do you think is gonna
happen with that wealth and equality so
I tend to be this you know nonconformist
thinking you know in terms of yeah I'm
not sure which box I belong and okay so
the inequality per se I don't think it's
what matters and I know that because I'm
a big proponent you know a big fan of
behavioral economics I understand that
the heuristics and the little traps that
we fall into psychologically right
listen as long as as long as the weakest
and the most disabled member of our
society has safe shelter access to safe
and nutritious food and access to
medical care I think we've done a great
job right so what we don't know and and
that what bothers me now yeah me too so
but that so and actually it's close to
like a couple billion people don't have
that so that is a problem right big why
it's a problem a humanistic problem
number one you can relate exactly made
you see other person suffer you feel for
them you want that to change to stop
right but also what you're doing is you
robbing yourself of the ingenuity
innovation and motivation that these
folks could have provided and they could
have invented stuff except provided
things so so I don't tend to focus on
the the gap so much as long as so in
other words if if I was either thinking
about bringing the baseline exactly so
to me that's number one clearly fairness
anthers the argument no matter what
right there's nothing we can do about
that's just human nature
people don't like if you're right about
focusing on the baseline moving up I
think that's a really good way to look
at things absolutely
there's the other side of the coin of
the conversation which is that it is
starting to look more and more like the
end of the middle class as though it is
you're either picking the super rich or
you're poor and at that point then a
speciation correct seems to be what is
going through destroy are you destroying
the fabric of society and that's such a
much into that and that is actually
could be as bad as artificial general
intelligence or bio warfare or any of
these up-and-coming major controversies
and that you know I can only hope the
humanity in the political class has
learned from the experience of the
French Revolution the German in 1920s
German society the Soviet Union the the
the incredible experiment in torturing
folks that I come from and other
societal in experiments I hope you
learned from that that by destroying the
the fabric where the majority of people
can safely navigate the streets can walk
around without fear of being robbed by
mobs of hungry
insecure I provided for people so I hope
we learn from that yeah absolutely
beyond that we haven't learned if faith
doesn't appear if we've learned yet
that's my pathological optimist you know
speaking because we look out a Market
Street our home here and we see half of
the people on the street are techies
yeah and half of the people are sleeping
on the street and that's unsheltered
people that I think and so this is a
it's a very strange dichotomy just out
the door 50/50 split and if a world if
we're Ron saying we haven't learned a
thing is because why are our resources
not you know being intelligently
allocated towards that process maybe
because we focus so much on creativity
and innovation and all these things you
know we got those little electric
scooters that cost $1 to start before we
took care of the person that's right
there on the street and they're parked
next to each other it's so interesting
how that occurred so
listen I agree and in fact I agree
completely in with what you're saying
very soberly is sort of the is a proof
point for the 2002 Nobel Prize in
Economics that was given to two
psychologists right kaname thirsty for
beer come on it's such a good book
we don't focus so all those fundamentals
are not sexy I don't know how to say the
politically correct okay whose
fundamentals aren't sex aren't sexy
nobody kid that's a good believe it or
not no one cares about providing
sufficient mental health housing all
those logistics right it's very
difficult to charm people into providing
social safety nets versus innovation
create exact but what about viewing
helping as innovation creativity some
people do do that so there are prizes
which is really a good way to motivate
people to prizes and that's why so that
goes back to precisely that goes back to
my realization that I can either
complain that the entire world doesn't
care about my cancer patients or I can
community find a way to communicate and
make it sound important yeah so again it
goes back to motivation it goes back to
being able to to marshal those resources
yeah
but communication is a skill difficult
it's a difficult challenge so and that
is obviously a lot of what we do on this
program as we try and take the
brilliance of so many people communicate
it relatedly to get people inspired and
to get them to take action get them to
care more to share the content how about
do you think that we are in a computer
simulation so we are definitely in a
commune Oh in a sufficiently computer
manipulated age there is we're at the
point where there's not sufficient
amount of interference with in
collection of data taking place that at
least the younger generations are
sufficiently influenced they are
becoming inseparable
from Romeo called computer age the
digital age they navigate in the world
that now is almost like a blend of the
world real in digital yeah I see that in
my own kids I didn't pay Tientsin
in my patients kids yeah the iPhone iPad
baby you know and now the interaction
that we have even its physicians without
without you know with our patients in
their in their children is very very
different so now not only so 5-10 years
ago we used to you know talk about you
know the doctor Google consult it's
actually much more sophisticated even ow
so you're dealing with chat rooms you're
dealing with all sorts of you know
sources of information that we never
used to even enter the conversation to
the physician and a patient for example
and I'm sure there's the domains of
these conversations when you make your
financial decisions when you when you
buy me a big item so when you
contemplating you know other serious
decisions in your life so it's it's
definitely changing I wonder if this
direct tie to the digital age is also
enriching more people to understand that
the world around us is could be
programmed digitally everything what do
you think is the most beautiful thing in
the world he said a thing so he gave me
a give me a ways out yeah sort of thing
so I would say I would say human mind
pretty close to that yeah it he so it's
been pushed to the brink before and you
know it seems to find its way out
sometimes eventually and sometimes not
right away sometimes not in most great
graceful ways but I think it's God
reserved and it's got enough of you know
built-in flexibility and agility to
really surprise us yet yeah I totally
agree I hope we I hope we survive past
next Fermi filters and I think hope is
the right statements writer awesome this
has been such a pleasure did you have a
good time I had a great time thank you
for probing and interesting questions
and I enjoyed this tremendously good I'm
really happy to hear that and we thank
you and your team for all your hard work
into pushing the brink of what's known
and unknown between healing our bodies
from what's actually occurring the
pathology so you're you're right there
you're at the forefront thank you very
much for doing that and we hope you
great success in your human clinical
trials thank you kindly
and I'm very grateful to my team and I'm
humbled by the tremendous tremendous
work that they're doing you thank you
you're you're you're incredible and I
really enjoyed your mind and your time
on the show let's close out we'll close
out to you guys we'll say thank you for
joining us we really appreciate it give
us a like give us a comment we'd love to
hear from you subscribe smash that
subscribe button join us in the
simulation community we'd greatly
appreciate it we have the enix biopharma
link in the bio go check them out reach
out to them do join us on patreon we
need your help we need this to be
sustainable we need it to grow over time
to get more of these little highlight
clips out there to grow into a massive
creative endeavor where we bring other
brilliant people in to try and change
the world and build a beautiful future
and ask more of these thought-provoking
questions so join us on patreon as well
thank you for tuning and share this
content with other people get them
inspired to think about it and we will
see you soon Thank You rod Vargas
producing partner boom see you later
[Music]
[Music]
you